So thank you,
everyone, for coming
to this breakout session.
I'm happy to have
this conversation,
actually I'm really
looking forward
to having this conversation
about making the most
of student evaluations.
And thanks for self-grouping
into some tables.
That's OK.
Somebody will figure that out.
You'll notice that
in front of you
there are some handouts
around a case study
that we'll comment
later on in the session.
So don't look at them yet.
If you are looking at them, just
put them back in the middle.
OK, so we are here to talk
about making the most of student
evaluations.
My name is Bill Wisser.
I'm the director of the
Teaching and Learning Lab,
and the lecturer in
education at the Graduate
School of Education.
Willis Emmons, director of the
Christensen Center Teaching
and Learning at Harvard
Business School.
And I'm Alexandra Sedlovskaya.
I'm the assistant director
at the Christensen Center
for Teaching and
Learning, and we'll also
have with us, our data analyst,
Tara Abbatello who is actually
doing a lot of our data analysis
around student evaluations.
Right Welcome.
Great.
So the title of
the session is very
important to framing
how we're going
to talk about
student evaluations,
making the most of
student evaluations.
Relations We're
thinking about it today
as formative instruments.
Ways for us to
improve our practice,
and how can we learn
from our students,
how can we learn from
our peers, and how can we
examine some
strategies that we use
to make the most of our
student evaluations.
And hopefully, by the
end of the session,
you'll walk away with some
new tools in your own toolkit
that you can apply when
you're doing your own.
I know that many of you
are-- or maybe close to half
of you aren't actually faculty
who are receiving student
evaluations, or some of
the student evaluations,
but through your work
with coaching faculty,
or developing strategies, and
also you're gathering and using
evaluations for workshops, and
from other events that you run.
We'd like to hear from you
about some of your strategies.
So the way this is
going to work is
I'm going to walk us through
a really brief exercise
to get us in that
formative frame of mind
to think about what's positive
about student evaluations.
Not ignoring that there
are some real challenges
with summative
evaluations as tools.
Well, we're going
to talk about what
are the formative elements
that we can pull of it,
and then we'll listen.
Alexandra will take us
through a really brief case
study about how they
analyzed student evaluations
over the business
school, and maybe serve
some generalizable strategies,
and takeaways from that.
And then finally, we'll
hear from some of your peers
from across the university
that we talked to
in advance of this
session, and also
learn from you about
some of the strategies
you use to examine your
student evaluations.
So to kick us off, what I'd like
to do is just think on your own
for a minute or two,
what's one thing that you
would like to learn
from your students
to improve your instruction.
Now, this is not about
your evaluations.
This is not about
your instrument
that your school uses.
One thing that you would like
to learn from your students.
So just think about it
for a minute or two.
Jot down an idea just quietly
by yourself for a minute.
OK, looks like most of the
pens have stopped moving.
Now take another couple minutes,
and just turn to the person
next to you, or two
people next to you.
What's your idea?
What's their idea?
Are there commonalities
in your interest
in learning from your students?
Something that you learn
from them, from your peer,
that you find interesting about
what they would like to learn.
Just take a minute or
two to share your ideas.
All right, so it sounds like
some great sharing going on,
some great ideas.
Hopefully, we'll be
able to capture them.
What I'd like to do now is just
hear from one or two tables
about one idea that you
heard from either your peers,
or something that you
brought up that you thought
was particularly salient
to this conversation
that we can keep in mind.
And I should say that
my colleague, Emily,
is going to take notes right
into the PowerPoint slide.
There will be a couple
opportunities for us
to gather notes from
you, and we'll then
share out the slides
after the session
so you'll have a record of this.
So what's one idea that you
heard from a table here?
This table, what's
one idea you'd
like to share that either
you brought up, or up here.
It's not one, it's
three, but I said,
why are you here, what
are your expectations,
and what are your goals?
OK, so you want to
learn from your students
why are you here, what are
your expectations, what
are your goals.
And of course, that
could be difficult
if we're only thinking
about evaluations
as being one
summative touch point
at the end of the semester.
You can think
about it moving on.
So what did I learn
from students last year
that I could apply?
But it's also to think
about that there's
a whole continuum of
evaluation or assessment
that you could employ
in your classrooms
from day one, all the way to
the end of class evaluation.
And student
evaluation instruments
are only just one
tool, one element.
Thanks Bill.
So our table, we found
that we basically all
had very similar ones.
That we only had one variation
of it that was helpful.
So what things do I do in
class that either increase
or decrease student
engagement, and basically,
how are ways that
you can determine
whether students are engaged.
How does that manifest?
How can you measure it?
How can you react to
it in a productive way
before you get students who are
hostile because they totally
tuned out.
Great.
So what are the
elements of instruction?
What are you doing to
encourage engagement?
Or what are you doing to
discourage engagement?
And then how do you know that?
How do we find out.
How can you tell?
How do you tell?
Right And one of the
strategies you'll hear later on
is thinking about
evaluations longitudinally.
Look at one question
over time, and see
how it changes based on
an input that you make.
How about one more.
How to measure engagement
An important idea
that came up here
was pre-assessment,
and understanding
the baseline
knowledge both to know
how to best reach
students, and also
to be able to measure correctly.
Great.
So pre-assessment, and thinking
about the actual student
evaluation instrument
as being your post-test,
and how did you garner
that pre-test material
to be able to access
it against the student
evaluations at the end.
But again, strategies-- these
will lead to strategies,
but what I wanted
to first think about
is what do you want to
learn from students.
Mean Think about the
student evaluation
at the end of the semester
as being one vehicle,
one channel to receive
that information.
,
Thanks, Bill.
So the next part
of our session is
going to be an
opportunity to actually do
a dive into the feedback that
one faculty member received
from a Harvard
Business School course.
And what I wanted
to do is to give
a little bit of an
overview just so you
have a frame of reference for
what the feedback was given
for, and then we're going to
have you work at your tables
to review some of the
data, and essentially,
do a bit of a group, a
little bit of diagnostic,
and then think about
what advice you
might give to this instructor.
And I think the
important thing that we
want to stress here
is that it's not
about specifically the content
of this Harvard Business School
class or format, but
to think about how--
what are ways that
you can use data.
Gary Keen talked
a lot this morning
about we have data,
to what extent
are we actually
harnessing that data,
using it in a productive way.
And we just wanted to share
with you at least the process
that we use at HBS, and
maybe spark some conversation
both about how it might
be useful for you,
but then what other ways that
you examine data, and again,
very much in a formative sense.
There was an earlier session
that I think a number of us
were at around using
these evaluations
for summative purposes,
and we're really
focusing on the development of
the faculty member formative
use.
So let me just leave
you a little bit
of a sense of the
context for HBS
because it will affect the
kind of feedback you see.
Virtually all of our courses
are taught by the case method.
And so the idea is that
in all of our classes,
it's a very
interactive discussion.
So this comment you
made about engagement
is a big part of what students
will notice or not notice,
and that comes up maybe
more in the feedback than
in some others.
We have no undergraduates.
This is going to all
be from an MBA class,
and so that might affect how
you're interpreting the data.
And just to tell you about
our first year MBA program,
for those of you
aren't familiar,
we have 900 students that
are spread over 10 sections.
On every day, for example,
in a marketing course,
they're all taking
the exact same course.
Effectively, the
syllabus is the same,
the case that they
use is the same,
and so there's an interesting
possibility of benchmarking
across various faculty, but
it also gives you the context.
You're in a room with
90 other students.
Class participation is
actually 50% of the grade.
So there's a lot of
pressure around engagement.
And we have a fixed curve.
So you wonder if these
valuations are somehow
shaped by grade inflation.
We don't have grade inflation.
So that's just a little
part of the context
that I wanted you
to be aware of.
So let me tell you a little
bit about the instrument that
is used at Harvard
Business School for student
evaluations of teaching.
We're not going to give
you the entire instrument,
but just to let you know, it
has one section for the course,
and one for the
instructor, and there
are separate questions for
the course and the instructor.
There are quantitative
ratings, very Likert scale type
questions only on
a few dimensions,
and this is for the instructor
we're going to focus on here.
The quality standards the
instructor use, the discussion
management, again, rating
managerial relevance
of the material,
and the learning.
Responsiveness to
students, student concerns.
And then the
question that I think
we all tend to
zero in on, what is
your assessment of the
overall effectiveness
of the instructor?
And I think as a headline
for what we try to do
is to move away from
the, I think, obsession
about the mean value of
this particular Likert scale
question.
Think about what
more broadly can
we learn about the
individuals teaching,
and really in an
action oriented way,
how can we provide
advice coaching
to help that
individual to continue
to improve as an instructor.
Now, to do that, we really
mind the qualitative questions,
and these are two very
open-ended questions.
One is what are two or three
things the instructor did
well, and should continue
to do, and the other
is two to three things to focus
on for improving effectiveness.
And one of the things that
we've done over the years.
And I'll give a
huge shout out here
to Tara Abatela, our
analyst, is actually
created a template and
a process for coding
every single comment
the students make,
and this allows us to
basically characterize
the types of feedback.
We find that
sometimes they'll just
comment on the instructor,
their style, their preparedness.
They'll comment on the process,
and clearly, case method
teaching involves
a lot of process.
And the other is on content,
the clarity of the content,
the richness, the scope.
And so what we're able to do
by coding the qualitative data
is actually create a summary
of strengths and opportunities
for that particular
faculty member in a visual
to see on which dimensions
there were strength comments,
or more opportunities.
And from that, try to
really investigate it
at a deeper level.
What are some of the drivers
of students assessment
of effectiveness, and frankly,
opportunities for improvement.
We're actually
able to do a couple
of other interesting things
in analyzing the data
because there's some demographic
information that we receive.
First of all, we ask a
question on the survey,
for each student
to assess, what was
your prior knowledge of the
field before taking the course,
from one to seven.
So that allows us to
actually cut the data
by novices versus experts,
and to what extent
do we see differences.
And frankly, when we look
at these mean ratings,
often, they're disguising
some real variation
in terms of the distribution
of those ratings,
and to the extent that there
may be some groups of students
who feel that the
learning was much more
effective than others.
It would be interesting to
be able to investigate that.
What would be some of
the underlying drivers.
Now, these surveys
are old anonymously,
but it's important
that we're able--
through the ideas that students
log in on to do surveys--
to identify gender
and citizenship,
whether they're US
or non-US citizens.
So that allows us to also
cut the data by gender,
by whether you're
US or non-US, which
can provide some additional
interesting insights.
And in fact, the way
we've set up the template
is that we can do that more
granular analysis on the Likert
scale questions, but
we can also do it
on the qualitative questions.
We can produce different
charts that reflect
the different demographics.
So that's the overview
that I wanted to give you
as to what you're going to see.
Now what you're going to
have in front of you--
and I encourage you now to grab
a little case study that you
have in front of you.
This is disguised, but
it's based on an actual HBS
professor, and this
professor, Dave Anderson,
is a first year instructor.
And you just have a little
bit of bio on the front page.
But let me just walk
you through what
you're going to be analyzing.
So the first page is,
essentially, a summary
of the Likert scale data.
So what were the mean ratings
on the various Likert scale
questions.
What was the distribution
of the instructor rating.
We had some ratings
by demographic group,
and at the bottom,
we actually see
how do the ratings differ
by prior knowledge.
So this is just to give you
a little bit of an overview
of how to read this.
Now, the second page is what
we call our red blue chart.
This is the visual
graphic that we're
able to generate by looking at
the strengths and opportunities
from the qualitative quotes.
And just to get
you oriented on how
to read, the scale
at the bottom, which
goes from 0 to 80,
and 0 to negative 80,
that's just the
number of surveys
that mentioned a particular
trait or a particular feature
of the class or
learning as being either
a straight or an opportunity.
Now, this is actually distilled
from the next two pages,
which are much more detailed.
So I'll just take
style as an example.
There were almost 80--
by the way, we have a
very high completion rate
because the surveys are done
on the last day of class
in the classroom,
and attendance is
close to 100% in the
business school classes.
So these are-- for a
class of 90 students--
will be very close
to that amount.
What was the 50%
number on your slide?
The class participation grade
is 50% of the overall grade.
So again, just to give
you an illustration
to be able to read
this more effectively.
Style, which is kind
of off the chart
as a positive for
this instructor, if we
go to what students are
saying about Dave Anderson's
style, energy, enthusiasm,
engagement, passion.
We can combine words
that are similar.
About 45 students
mentioned that.
Humor is another area, and then
basically, presentation style,
and you can do this for any one
of the elements on the chart.
And then finally, I want
to just draw your attention
to the last two pages
where we've selectively
pulled some quotations
from students that give you
even more granularity in terms
of what students are thinking,
and the feedback they're
giving on the course.
And I'll just highlight the
first one here on strengths.
At the end of the quote,
we have in parentheses,
some of the
demographic information
that we were able to distill.
So this first quote is from a
female student, a US citizen.
The seven is the
instructor rating
that she gave to
the faculty member.
So this is someone who gave
a seven to the instructor,
a seven out of seven,
and the prior six
is someone who was
self assessed as having
been pretty knowledgeable
about the course
before taking the course.
So that gives you a
little bit of sense
where are these
quotations coming
from in terms of a little bit of
the background of the students.
So what we would love for you to
do is to gather around a table.
I know most of you are, but
for those of you who aren't,
if maybe you could cluster--
either join another
table, or create your own.
And I want you to just
individually take a few minutes
to read through the data.
Come up with your own,
I would say, diagnostic.
What's the sort of
theory of the case
for this particular instructor.
And then think about
what advice that you
would give the
instructor if you had
even two or three high level
recommendations to improve
teaching.
Read a little bit, think
about this on your own,
and then I'll have
you gather, and talk
a little bit n your groups.
And we will circulate
to the extent
that you have some questions
about how to read the data.
Do you have a--
Sorry, can I ask you
a quick question?
Sure.
The prior reading scale,
how does that work?
Yeah, so the student
is asked to assess
what was your prior
understanding of the field
before taking the course
from one to seven.
So it's self-reported, but it's
usually a pretty good indicator
if it's a completely new
or varied experience.
So why don't we take about
five minutes on your own,
and then gather in your groups,
and then we'll do a debrief,
get a sense of what
your assessments are
of the information.
I know it's very
hard to break away.
I hear these intense
discussions about Dave Anderson.
And as sort of a
bridge, there were
a couple of questions that came
up as I was circulating around,
and I did want to
clarify a few things.
First of all, of
this is voluntary.
Faculty come to us to
look at their evaluations.
No one is required to have this
analysis done, and non of this
is part of the
promotion's process.
The Christensen Center is not
involved at all in promotion.
And the last thing I'll say,
just in terms of the principal,
it was an interesting
comment that I
think Doug Milton made this
morning about how hard it
is when you see one or two
quotes that really drive
you crazy as a faculty member.
There are a number
of faculty members
who don't read the feedback,
but they give it to us,
and I think sometimes
these red blue charts
kind of take some of the
emotion away in terms of--
actually, two people said it,
and it may stick in your call
that only two people
said it, and you
see that on the diagram.
But those are just a
few contextual factors.
But I think the more interesting
question is what did you
think about Dave Anderson?
What's your theory of the case?
What's your diagnosis?
And then if you had to give
a couple of recommendations
to him to improve his
teaching, what would that be?
So would anyone like to kick
that off from your tables?
So our feeling was that he's
doing this for the first time.
He's learning to do this.
He's bringing a
lot of knowledge,
a lot of enthusiasm
to the classroom,
but that perhaps maybe the
focus for him is on him.
That he's really thinking about
what he's going to do next.
He summarizes well at
the end of the case.
So the parts that he
does, he does well,
but it's coming at a
cost of really listening
to, and understanding
the students,
and he's not really facilitating
student-student interactions as
well as he might, or
really building off
of student comments.
And so our
recommendation for him
really would be to
relax a little bit,
and really try to
hear, and engage,
and bring in the students
into the conversation.
Great, thank you.
Other groups, what
would you add to that
in terms of some of the
diagnosis or some of--
I'm going to pass that
maybe back behind you,
and we'll go around.
One of those things our group
noticed was while his style--
he got great strengths in his
style from the open comments,
we gleaned that the women,
and non-US women in particular
are not as enamored,
that this style is
working as well for them.
And why do you
think that's true?
Why do we think it's true?
Well, drawing on
prior experience,
I thought he's probably
more of a bro style.
A lecture that maybe
some of his jokes
are resonating
more with US males
than they are with
females, and they
might be gender jokes that
are missing the mark a little.
That would be-- it's
hard to tell, exactly.
Well there is one quote
that would support that.
It was from a male that
it was frat house humor.
I wish I had seen a female who
had given a better indication,
but we thought that that male
could be highly observant,
and that certainly resonated
with some of the things
that we were suspecting.
Yeah, and I think that's one of
the things that's really both
intriguing, and sometimes tricky
about this analysis is that you
can have some hypotheses
that you're generating,
that some of that
data-- for example,
that low mean rating or lower
mean rating from the US--
I'm sorry, the female
non-US students,
and why is that the case.
And sometimes you can find
some support or evidence
in the qualitative data.
I was saying
earlier that we also
perhaps, had done an observation
of this faculty member
during the semester.
We may have other data.
There may have been
some midterm surveys.
So there may be
additional ways, but it
is kind of forensic
analysis to some extent.
And even when we meet
with a faculty member,
we usually meet for
about 90 minutes.
It's a long debrief.
It's actually started with
a lot of self-reflection.
We ask the faculty
member to reflect
on what they felt went
particularly well,
things they would do
differently next year,
and if they had read the
feedback themselves, what
surprised them in the feedback.
And that could be an
ongoing exploration where
we may be trying to test
out some of the hypothesis,
but I think this was
absolutely affirmed,
I think, and the
faculty member even
was able to recall a couple
of jokes or jokey moments
that added to your sense.
I saw a hand here earlier.
Was there a--
No, I was very
struck by the fact
that he can't run a seminar.
I mean, he can't listen.
I thought maybe some Ritalin.
No, I mean seriously.
So the question is
OK, obviously, he
can't run a seminar that
everybody feels good
about The question is
what to do about it.
I'm very interested
in that because I also
don't know how to run a seminar
I'm a physics professor, so I
don't really have to most of
the time but I'm thinking drugs
might be a--
[LAUGHTER]
Just so that you don't-- he
sounds like he's interrupting
a lot, and stuff like that, and
maybe if he just took a little
bit of something
to repress his--
but I'm actually kind
of interested in what
you would suggest,
but it's not obvious
that just you talking to
him could help him do that.
And I think one of the
things we'll do sometimes
is actually go over some video
footage, if we have video,
so the faculty member can see
what they're like in the class,
experience themselves.
But you're right, some
of this becomes really
a process of thinking
maybe doing some role play.
We'll do some practicums, try
to work with the faculty, even
some advice.
Why don't you wait to hear a few
students before interjecting.
Give them some things
to practice on.
This is a process of give
and take along the way.
I'm going to be very--
this is so hard for me
to stop this discussion because
I feel that we're just touching
the tip of the
iceberg, but I'm also
sensitive to what we have left
on the rest of the agenda.
I hope this gives you
a taste for what we do,
and I'll be happy to chat,
as will Alexandra and Atara
afterwards about both
the methodology, the kind
of insights we derived.
But I think what
I wanted us to do
in the next just sort of pulling
together, is share with you
a few general lessons, and I'll
hand this over to Alexandra
to pull together a bit
of what we've learned.
Great.
Well first of all, thank
you for sharing your ideas.
As I was walking
around, I definitely
had seen very rich conversations
happening all around the room.
So very quickly, just
trying to pull it together.
Let me just find the clicker.
It's right here.
Fantastic.
So very quickly, pulling
the main insights,
and just sharing what we've
learned over the years doing
this analysis.
Well, first, I think it
became obvious even here,
just the richness of qualitative
data, which again, moves us
beyond that one defining,
as Willis had mentioned,
statistic of our mean
teaching effectiveness,
to really start unpacking
that number from the more
developmental standpoint.
And as we look through
the qualitative data,
and I think we've heard this
already from the panel earlier,
it is important
to systematically
to avoid this issue
of selective reading.
Even the most established
professors sometimes
feel jittery looking at
the negative feedback,
or get fixated on one, as
was mentioned, completely
unrepresentative, but very, very
strongly worded comment that
overshadows the rest
of the feedback,
and that's not very helpful.
And also just even
if you dare to look
through all the comments,
just the sheer number
could become overwhelming.
All the noise, or it might
look like it's noise,
comments that are contradictory.
We talked about Dave
Anderson's humor.
Some say use more humor,
others say joke less.
Is it a wash?
Well, and as I think we've
already pointed out here,
it's not either/or.
It's really maybe
humor is good, but it's
the types of jokes
he's making that would
be alienating to certain
groups of people,
as you had mentioned.
And so it's really looking
at the qualitative data
to get this deeper understanding
of what's really going on,
which is not to suggest that
quantitative data does not
matter.
They do.
It's just, again, moving beyond
the quantitative statistics.
So perhaps, looking at the
distribution of readings.
I don't know how
many of you noticed,
I know you had very short
time, but Dave Anderson's
mean reading is five, but he's
moral rating is actually six.
So it might be worthwhile
to think about what's
bringing down his
teaching effectiveness,
or this perceived teaching
effectiveness here.
And I know when we do
research, sometimes we
say not to focus
on the outliers;
sometimes, it could
be just outliers.
But it might be worthwhile,
for example, in this case,
to spend some time on this
lower end of the distribution
to see whether there is a
certain group of students that
are just systematically not
learning as effectively as they
could.
So am I not engaging
my experts adequately?
Am I losing my novices?
Am I not resonating my
knowledge, as an example,
just not resonating with
my international students.
And then in which case,
having this information
about our students
will be very helpful.
The demographic
characteristics, or we
talked about prior
knowledge, but again,
using this
information carefully.
So we don't want to
dismiss, as we said,
non-US female students.
We don't want to say, well, they
just don't like Dave Anderson.
What am I going to do?
It's more just understanding
how can be effective with groups
from different backgrounds.
And finally, as we look
through the comments,
it could be very
compelling to say well,
it's just not the reality here.
Dave Anderson may
very well feel,
I am listening to students.
We talked about not
listening, but he might feel
I'm listening very actively.
I care deeply about
what they're saying.
So here, the question
really is, why do they
feel like I'm not listening?
What can I do to change
their perceptions?
And I think taking
this perspective,
as we've talked
about Dave Anderson,
and he's listening to students,
I think in the faculty role,
as we listen to students,
taking their perspective,
giving voice to students,
to then hopefully help
us improve in the classroom.
So this is just one
approach you've been taking.
I know you've been
commenting about the process.
Of course, a lot of
credit goes to Tara,
and this is just
one way of doing it.
So I'm going to
turn it over to Bill
to talk about some
other strategies
that he's been hearing
about across Harvard
from our other colleagues.
So I want to echo that last
point that Alexandra just made.
That you saw one
methodology that
was very labor intensive
to do, and obviously,
it was developed over time,
and it was very powerful
when working with faculty.
And you may not have access
to those types of resources,
or that type of modeling
that you can do on your own,
or even with peers.
But what can you do?
What are some
strategies or takeaways
that you can apply to your
own student evaluations?
So we went on a bit
of a listening tour,
and through the Box Center
at FAS, and through SLATE
at Kennedy school, and then
through the HGSC Teaching
and Learning Lab, and
the Christensen Center,
and talked to some
faculty about what
are some of their
strategies that they
use when they think about
their own student evaluations.
And we did a very light-weight
grouping in organization,
but came up with some
common approaches
to think about
their evaluations.
First we heard from a
lot of faculty members,
it the student end of term
evaluation is just one tool,
is just one instruments.
And that should never
be the only feedback
you get from students, the only
time you hear from students
about how the class is
going, what they're learning,
what challenges
they face, and there
are many different formative
assessment approaches
that you can use
throughout the semester
to learn from your students.
Second piece of advice that
several faculty shared was we
often teach in
similar content areas,
and in similar
domain areas, maybe
with similar types of
students, and similar types
of class sizes.
Maybe having some--
take some time
and go out for coffee,
and just share some ideas.
You don't have to pass around
the instrument, especially
if you're concerned about
those outlier comments,
and you don't want
your colleague to know.
But if you're having a challenge
with engagement, for example,
in a large lecture class,
and you're hearing this
from your student
evaluations, maybe there's
one or two peers that
have figured that out,
or have used their
evaluations to figure out
some incremental
changes they could make.
Another strategy was looking
at one or two questions
that you think are particularly
get at what you're trying
to achieve in the classroom.
One faculty member I talked
to was very interested in
whether students felt
supported in their learning.
Do they have the tools
and support structures
to become better in this
topic area, whatever it is,
because she knows
that she's never
going to be able to
teach them everything.
She's setting them up
to be lifelong learners.
Do they feel like they are
developing that support
structure?
And she uses two questions
on her evaluations
to get at that information,
and looks at it over time.
And the last one, just
sort of echoing that point,
is another faculty member I
talked to at the Ed school,
he looks at just one-- well,
he looks at the whole thing,
of course, but he hones in
on one specific question
over time, that he is very
interested in seeing how
his course develops over time.
So any incremental changes
he makes to the course,
he uses that one question
as a record of that change.
In what way did it move
the needle in a way
that he thought
would be powerful?
So these, remember,
we're going to--
if you RSVPd for
the conference, we
have your contact
information, and we will
share this slide deck with you.
But now I want to hear, just for
a minute, as we're wrapping up,
what are some of
your strategies.
So if the technology works,
there is a poll that is active.
What's one thing you use
in your own teaching,
one way of approaching
your student evaluations,
one strategy that
you found effective.
[LAUGHTER]
And keeping with the drug theme.
How would you deal with
your student evaluations?
So we see one there,
the plus delta
at the end of every
class meeting.
That's in line with thinking
of the student evaluations
as being one tool,
one on a continuum
of different formative
assessment tools.
Thinking about the entire
evaluation as a whole.
That's one way of getting
past those outlier comments.
Maybe give it some time,
let it sit for a while,
and then look at
holistically, the evaluation.
Yeah, the focus group,
you're diving deeper
in particular questions.
You can do that,
of course, any time
during the semester as well,
especially when you still
have them as students.
Do a mid-course evaluation, and
follow up with a focus group.
Just a light-weight
conversation.
Not calling out
particular names,
but this is a theme that came
up in the midterm evaluation.
I'd like to unpack
it a little bit.
Set outliers aside,
or just ignore them.
Ignore the open resources.
That's a strategy.
Does anyone have a
strategy, but they
don't have a device with
them, a way of using the poll,
but they'd like to share one?
Yes.
Actually look at the outliers.
Look at the outliers?
Yes.
OK.
Because the average-- we always
study the average all the time.
And you think the outliers
provide you a unique insight
or a powerful insight?
Powerful insight in
terms of not dragging
for example, for Dave Anderson,
is the outliers at the very
left give scores
of one or two that
drag his mean down
to five, and those
could be the non-US females.
Yes.
Our teacher evaluations
are public to the student
population, and so I
just reference them
at the beginning of each course.
Say this is what
went well last time,
this is what we're working on.
Keep me accountable on the
things that we're working on,
and let me know.
And I put the plus delta I use
that as a place to touch base.
Where is that?
At the Harvard School
of Public Health.
So every comment is
available for them to see?
Yeah.
Which is true of the
ED school as well.
It is.
For every question.
Whoa.
So does that just mean
people don't say mean things?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow, that's interesting.
And they are used.
At the ED school, they
are used for students
when they're thinking about
selecting into courses.
They will review the evaluations
to see what they will learn,
what the class setup is
like the structure is like.
They find-- student
find them useful.
OK, so again, we will
collect these ideas.
Or we have collected the ideas.
We will share them with
you, and hopefully, you
will find some of these
strategies useful.
As a way of moving on with
getting back into the classroom
ourselves, including a class
that I teach at 1:00 today,
why are we doing this?
Why do we care?
Why should we care?
And this quote from C. Roland
Christensen, at the business
school, thinking about
what respect can we
show our students?
What value can we take from
them, and give back to them
about what it means to be an
effective instructor, what
it means to provide then a
powerful learning experience.
So thanks for your time.
We have a minute
or so left if you'd
like to talk to
any of us, or ask
more questions
about the strategy,
or particularly, the technique
that Willis uses over
at the Christensen Center.
We'd be happy to talk more.
I do have one quick
thing that I thought
I would mention that we started
doing the last few years,
and I think has been really
powerful is that when we--
particularly, working with
a newer faculty member,
we ask them if they would like
to bring with them a teaching
mentor to the debrief meeting.
And we found them actually
quite receptive to that,
and that begins a
conversation with someone
who is close to them
in terms of the content
that they're teaching, and
is also helping build trust.
We heard about
trust this morning
as being such an important
part of this process,
and I think that's been
something that we--
that's becoming more
of a norm, and faculty
were comfortable with it.
I think that's been a
very positive development.
I just wanted to
share that with you.
Can I ask one
question real quick?
In FAS, they spend a lot of time
videotaping people, and then
going over the video tapes.
Have you found that that's--
how helpful is that, actually?
As
It's funny, we do that
right at the beginning.
We do a practicum.
All of our faculty are required
to come to a program called
Start in July.
It's a three day program,
and they experience
some case-method teaching
in that program as students,
and then each of them gets up,
and teaches for 10 minutes.
This is really borrowed
from the Box center,
and then they give a little
pure feedback to each other.
But then we offer, as
the Christensen Center,
a two-hour debrief to talk
about teaching in general,
but to basically go through, and
deconstruct their 10 minutes.
There's a huge amount of
information in that 10 minutes,
and it begins the relationship
that we then carry through.
I would say during
the semester, it's not
unusual to have
a class recorded,
and then we may
review that recording,
and share feedback with them.
But we would rarely watch
the video with them.
Or if we do, it's maybe
just a segment of the video.
But we try to get
them to appreciate,
and they'll watch
videos of themselves.
Good.
Continue with questions.
Thank you so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]